un collègue arrive m'explique qu'il ya
de la fumée dans le couloir et que les
autres collègues sont déjà partis ceci
est un exercice de sécurité incendie
version réalité virtuelle un outil de
formation pour plonger l'utilisateur
dans une expérience proche du réel avec
un feu d'ordinateur tout autour de moi
j'ai des portes et au dessus d'une des
portes je vois de la fumée s'échapper
j'ai remarqué que j'avais des
extincteurs à la disposition je peut
sonner l'alarmé
je peux enlever la goupille de
l'extincteur
et puis éteindre le feu comme dans la
réalité en appuyant sur la manette et
j'ai une statistique qui me dit que j'ai
déclenché l'alarmé au bout de 30
secondes que l'électricité n'a pas été
coupée chose que j'aurais dû faire
j'ai éteint le feu en une minute 11
secondes je n'ai pas vidé l'extincteur
alors qu'il aurait fallu le faire et
j'ai une prédiction de 100% à l'origine
des images et de la programmation de ce
scénario la start-up 4d créée à une
expérience de réalité virtuelle avec
l'intégration d'objets réels qu'on a les
distinctes heures ici qui sont équipés
d'un de deux tracker qu'il permet d'être
repérés dans l'espace par le système de
rester virtuel qui sont ici et puis on
en a un second qui permet de savoir
comment et positionner la lance et puis
on a associé les interrupteurs pour
savoir quand la personne enlève la
goupille donc à un extincteur et aussi
quand elle active la start-up 4 décret a
été lancé en 2009 spécialisée d'abord
dans la vidéo elle s'est tournée vers la
réalité virtuelle grâce à une commande
de bouygues construction en 2012
en travaillant à la présentation du
siège de bouygues construction
on a fait une application tactile une
visite 3d qui permettait de découvrir
l'ensemble des bâtiments et des
innovations mises en oeuvre au fil des
années les technologies ont évolué les
casques de réalité virtuelle se sont
transformés et les possibilités se sont
élargies création du concept et des
graphiques élaboration des scénarios
cadets créa collabore avec des grands
groupes du secteur de la mode de
l'automobile ou encore du numérique
ici c'est une expérience de réalité
virtuelle à plusieurs joueurs et en full
body
donc on a la possibilité de voir son
corps en entier bras corps jambes de
voir la partenaire avec qui on joue ou
le partenaire et puis de l'ensemble du
décor est rendue tangibles et
aujourd'hui on arrive sur un métier qui
est très très dans le développement
informatique
puisqu'au créer des interactions
complexes aujourd'hui qu'à décret a
réalisé un chiffre d'affaires de 500
mille euros avec une croissance annuelle
moyenne de 30%